high above the swiss alps we're on our
way to see climate change in action the
nourishing area of the glacier is now we
don't have much snow at the moment the
ice is melting at an unprecedented rate
revealing a wreckage hidden long ago
on alleged glacier this aircraft lost in
the 1960s has re-emerged
first i saw the wings where you can see
now here
i saw the seats over there
i saw an eyeglass case with the nivea
cream still looking good
and i saw a wet hot
and damaged objects distributed in the
area
here they found a plane on two nearby
glaciers two bodies have been unearthed
those lost to the ice discovered in
switzerland's great thor
the glaciers are disappearing they say
when it continues like this in the year
2090 they will be only remaining 10
percent of the glacier
switzerland's 1400 glaciers have lost
half of their total volume in less than
a century
another pressure on water supplies in a
time of widespread drought
we can see the problem up here it's for
the whole europe or for the whole world
because of the water not only we need
the water all europe need to water from
here at nearby glacier 3000 the
consequences of climate change are also
apparent
a path iced over since roman times is
now revealed
so you can see this rock i'm walking on
and until recently this was all covered
in ice but now this thin sliver between
the two sections of rock is all that
remains and for the first time in more
than 2 000 years this path is going to
be revealed and that's a direct
consequence of climate change they've
had little snow in the winter a warm
spring and exceptionally hot summer and
that means they're expecting to lose
more than three times the amount of ice
than they usually do
these photos show how starkly glacial
ice has receded
here say rouge glacier is expected to
totally disappear in the next 15 years
on rhona glacier scientists are mapping
the changes how quickly the ice is
moving how much has melted
here a huge section has already
collapsed
the situation for glaciers is really
poor it may well be kind of the worst
year we have will have on records what's
the cause and what happens if we don't
stop it and save the glaciers well the
course of glacier retreat is well
established that's due to rising
temperatures which are linked obviously
to the ongoing climate change that we
have it's not only affecting glaciers
but it's affecting also many other
compartments of their system
so like drought
heat waves glacier melt they're all
connected
absolutely for some it's already too
late
some glaciers will be gone in 15 years
the future of the rest depends on us
our desire and ability to slow the
global warming heating up our world
siobhan robbins sky news switzerland